the views and opinions expressed on this
program are those of the guests
appearing on the program and do not
necessarily reflect the views and
opinions of eight news now or next our
media group
i recognize that it is a controversial
issue
but i also recognize that the state of
nevada is pretty split
on whether we should keep the death
penalty or abolish it tonight on
politics now district attorney steve
wolfson talks to us about his support
for the death penalty and plea deals
plus
has there been any buzz
on rent control
don't say those words
what's behind surging rents and what the
solution may be and
that's my mission that's what gets me up
in the morning henderson candidate for
mayor dan stewart who wants to see his
city form its own school district
from 8 news now this is politics now
district attorney steve wolfson says his
new priority will be diversion programs
for low-level offenders in the court
system thanks for joining us i'm vanessa
murphy john langler is off wolfson has
been in office since 2012 and he plans
on staying there john talked with him
about the 2022 d.a race
one of your pitches your that you've
highlighted during your time there smart
reform programs diversion programs
explore a little bit what the programs
are and how they have
have they worked as they've been put
into the justice system
well what we've learned over the years
is we have to be a little smarter about
how we do business in the criminal
justice system
so we've started redefining and
refocusing our priorities and one of the
things we've created is a program called
project redirect
it is a diversionary program it's the
first of its kind in nevada
we realize that most cases never go to
trial and most cases involving low-level
non-violent offenders get resolved in a
plea bargain they get misdemeanors or
sometimes even dismissals
but we want to offer certain treatment
programs to these people if there are
victims and restitution is owed we want
to collect that restitution so we
created project redirect which diverts
people out of the system are you willing
to discuss possibly adjusting
your use of the death penalty in in
prosecution well yes absolutely and i
have engaged in those discussions and i
continue to engage in those discussions
but a little history is appropriate
my predecessor filed almost 20 death
penalty cases a year
before i took office uh my first six
seven years i reduced that number to
under 10 so i cut the number of death
penalty cases in half and in the last
two or three years i've only filed a
handful because i recognize
the state of nevada has not executed
anybody since 2006
and just a couple of years ago when a
very violent person who was convicted of
a couple of homicides where the jury
created not created but invoked the
death penalty and he wanted to be
executed and we still couldn't execute
mr dozer and he ended up committed
committing suicide in prison
i recognize that it is a controversial
issue
but i also recognize that the state of
nevada is pretty split on whether we
should keep the death penalty or abolish
it i've even suggested perhaps a
referendum
let's educate nevadans on both sides of
the issue
so that nevadans can speak up and voice
their opinion there has been some
questions raised about why grand juries
have been called in certain cases i'm
thinking of the officer kenneth lapera
case there's a couple other ones as well
the byron williams jorge gomez cases
educate the viewers if you can why you
called grand juries in those cases and
if you think that was the appropriate
method of trying to find resolution the
lapera case that was the officer
we took that case to the grand jury
because we wanted to see if we could
move it into district court but that
grand jury
failed to find probable cause
so that's a body of citizens that
listened to the evidence and said we
don't think there's enough evidence to
proceed
how would you characterize the effort by
prosecutors in that case to actually
prosecute officer lopera
i had some of my best prosecutors
working that case
but the officer had good lawyers
themselves
these lawyers presented us with another
side to the story
we are required by law to present
what is called exculpatory evidence
to the grand jury that's evidence that
tends to negate guilt we are required by
law to present that which is what we did
so after a full
uh investigation and after a full
presentation to the grand jury that
grand jury saw fit not to indict that
officer one of the accusations that's
been made uh and it's kind of coming out
in this race so far is that you as as
d.a
give sort of sweetheart deals to bigger
name attorneys in in las vegas uh david
chesnov among others
do you what do you say to those
accusations that when you're talking
about settling cases before they even
get to trial some of the high-powered
attorneys here in las vegas
get um
the benefit of the da's office
yeah i wonder um
what those muckrackers which mr john
ralston referred to them as
whether or not they did enough research
because it's my understanding that mr
chesnov has challenged those accusations
i challenge those accusations as well
there was an individual represented by
mr chesnov
that was found guilty of a very serious
felony dui involving death and injury
ask that gentleman if he thinks that his
lawyer got special treatment
because that gentleman is now serving a
significant prison sentence
there's another case in the system right
now involving a basketball player
where
a certain charge was dismissed
in a proceeding and we're still moving
forward on that case notwithstanding who
his lawyer is so i take exception to the
accusation that certain lawyers get
special deals
we evaluate cases on a case-by-case
basis john and we look at the strength
or weakness the merits of the case when
we decide how to handle it
the dui case district attorney wolfson
referenced is scott gregson a person was
killed in that crash he's serving eight
to 20 years in prison the other is aeon
collins who was a basketball player
heading to unlv that case is still
working its way through the court system
by the way david chesnov's attorney
reached out after that interview she
told us there's a retraction being
issued by the people who made that
accusation of favoritism from the da's
office
that whole interview with d.a wolfson
will be at eight newsnow dot com so far
his only challenger is ozzie fumo who
like wolfson is a democrat wolfson did
not face a republican challenger in 2018
either so he won re-election when he won
the democratic primary
well the rent is way too high that's
what many people in the valley are
saying right now according to zillow our
rents are increasing at the second
fastest rate in the country just behind
phoenix so what's causing the rapid
spike i talked with susie vasquez of the
nevada state department association to
find out
we keep hearing from viewers about
the rent going up and not just like 25
but like 200 300 400
what's behind this
primarily the rent increases can be
attributed to
the supply
or the lack thereof so typically we have
about 10 to 11 000 units available in
clark county
but we're currently at 6800 units
so that is a significantly low amount of
available units
when you're talking about people moving
from out of state are you are we
referring to mainly californians i mean
i know it varies but is that a huge
chunk
a huge chunk
i can't remember what the percentage is
but it is close to 40 percent of the
people that are moving to nevada are
directly from california has there been
any buzz
on rent control
don't say those words
i thought that would be your response
it is um i mean if you can find a
program
a rent control program somewhere in this
nation that actually works i'd be more
than happy to have a conversation around
it we have yet to see a program that
actually works it really is
just a band-aid that
makes it worse
it's a temporary solution
for
a supply problem
also this week the u.s supreme court
struck down the cdc's eviction
moratorium so we're keeping an eye on
how much evictions may pick back up but
nevada offers some protections through
an assembly bill in the meantime we have
plenty of resources for those who need
help and what to do if you're facing an
eviction at eight newsnow dot com
tempers flared over an anti-racism
policy for schools during this week's
ccsd board of trustees meeting district
leaders presented a timeline for their
plan 8 news now's sasha loftis was there
for all of the fireworks
[Applause]
turmoil takes center stage at yet
another ccsd board of trustees meeting
dr barton does a great job in
understanding all the training parents
teachers and students spoke out on a
district-wide anti-racism policy our
children are not protected
they are not being protected many pushed
for progress demanding concrete policies
in schools now while others are against
any action it's become clear that
we're just not you know we're on such
different pages
and
we just have totally different views
this topic was first touched on back in
june after this year's passage of nevada
assembly bill 371 which includes racial
discrimination and existing laws related
to bullying discrimination based on race
bullying and cyber bullying on thursday
the first timeline to develop this
policy in ccsd was presented with a
mention of staff education and community
accountability i've already heard the
word n-word said to me multiple times
i've had teachers tell me that i don't
have a future because i'm black a final
adoption is set for january but many
students say they're suffering now and
they're asking for immediate change our
kids just have to continue to go through
this we're not standing for it to move
toward a better experience in the
classroom i deserve to go to the class
and not feel scared sasha loftis 8 news
now
the district also formed a task force to
help with the development of anti-racism
policies it was made clear that critical
race theory would not be part of any
plan moving forward
wanting to break up ccsd
it's going to be long it's going to be
hard but it's worth the effort up next
on politics now henderson candidate for
mayor dan stewart talks to us about why
his top priority is getting the city its
own school district
welcome back to politics now
two members of the henderson city
council are hoping to upgrade to mayor
dan stewart has been on the council
since 2017. his opponent is michelle
romero john langler talked with dan
stewart about his vision for the city
first question why do you want to be
mayor well i think
probably most important two things even
most importantly is i think we've we've
reached a critical point in the growth
and evolution of our city
that i think we really need some
sophisticated
thought and planning
to
to take us into that next step but most
importantly
i've got to tell you i want to
lead the charge in taking back control
of our schools
you mentioned school district you
started a pac i believe
there's
you are
determined to separate henderson school
district for henderson from ccsd
why
well
the easy answer
which is the truth is ccsd is just too
big it's just become
unyielding it just
it's we can't get anything done it's too
big
the uh it's just the morass of red tape
and we need to have local control
parents need to be able to be more
involved with their own with their own
children and their the children's
education and the only way to do that is
to make school districts smaller how do
you plan to differentiate yourself from
your opponent considering if you look
just sort of you know one against one a
lot of your positions are pretty similar
in terms of your vision for the future
the economic development aspect the
school district aspect public safety
there's not a whole lot of difference is
there so there's huge differences so
tell me about what they are
the perspective i have been 40 45 years
in this valley and i'm a businessman i
come from a total
businessman's point of view business
person's point of view excuse me and we
you know that perspective is necessary
to get these hard things done
and uh perspective is everything i come
from the taxpayer i come from a customer
of government i've worked through
government and the red tape my entire
life how much of a change from the
current course of action do you
anticipate if you become mayor
is it status quo or is it okay i'm mayor
stewart
we're gonna chart a little bit of a
different course here um that's that's a
very good question i'm not one to come
in and
wave my arms i'm saying we need to
change we need to change i think we need
to course correct a little bit how so
just elaborate that a little bit more if
you can again back to that point of
becoming a little more sophisticated
what does that mean sophisticated didn't
i know it's not it means but like in
terms of city development
uh
sustainable growth not just sustainable
growth but and development with us a
sustainable community how do we
continue to be the henderson that we are
and that we love and we love being part
of
but how do we anticipate and plan for
the future growth growth is coming we
just need to make sure we do it in the
right proper way the number one priority
in your view for henderson moving
forward
take control of the schools
our own schools that's that's my mission
that's what gets me up in the morning
i'm passionate about it
we're going to make this happen
as you can tell dan stewart really wants
to break up the school district
henderson racers for mayor are
nonpartisan but both stewart and romero
are republicans you can watch that full
interview and our interview with romero
at eight newsnow dot com
nevada will not be joining a group of
states which have an agreement with drug
companies over opioid lawsuits 44 states
are signing on to the settlement with
johnson and johnson and other drug
companies that make prescription opioids
nevada would have received 282 million
of the total 26 billion dollar deal
attorney general aaron ford thinks
nevada can get more than of that on its
own he says nevada will be making its
own settlements which he's calling the
one nevada agreement that will allow
individual counties to be part of them
as well
attorney segal chatta a republican
running against ford for attorney
general criticized the decision saying
in part nearly every state has signed on
to the opioid settlement except for
aaron ford who appears to be looking out
for his former employer more than he's
looking out for his current employer
nevada's citizens the law for firm
representing nine nevada counties or
cities in their lawsuits is ford's
former employer eglet prince
desperate to save his family
my wife she's out of the danger zone and
i'm focused on saving uh everybody else
up next an afghan who helped the us
military and now lives in las vegas
desperate to get his family out and to
safety
you're watching politics now
at least two explosions in kabul on
thursday killed at least 12 u.s service
members and 200 afghans pentagon
officials warned there's a very real
threat of additional terrorist attacks
in kabul and say that if the u.s can
find those responsible for the attack in
kabul the u.s military will respond u.s
officials say a suicide bomber is
responsible for an explosion that killed
12 u.s service members and injured 15
more there are also a number of
additional reported attacks and at least
60 afghans have been killed
the attack on the abbey gate was
followed by a number of isis gunmen who
opened fire on civilians and military
forces
pentagon officials say there was clearly
a failure because the attackers passed
through several checkpoints controlled
by the taliban or afghan forces before
reaching the airport gates and u.s
troops
now to the story of an afghan who worked
as a special ops translator and now
lives in las vegas he has been working
to get his wife out of afghanistan and
to america safely in the meantime she
has been hiding from the taliban that is
why we're protecting their identity in
this story kirsten joyce tells us how
she's making it out
she is safe words h.k has been waiting
to share since i first met him two weeks
ago 15 days that i haven't had
probably no more than two hours
of sleep at night h.k lives in las vegas
where he became a u.s citizen last year
he and his wife got married in
afghanistan and he's been working for a
year to supply her with the proper
documents to come to the states
after the taliban takeover he was scared
for his wife's life she had to hide out
just 10 minutes from the airport in
kabul there was times of over 9 000
people around the airport it was a
humanitarian disaster hk worked day and
night with a variety of contacts to get
her safely to the airport folks he met
through his time as a translator helping
the u.s military in afghanistan for
nearly a decade his journey and efforts
being documented by his friend brian
johnson a guy who speaks five languages
that's beloved by the us military by
special forces that has worked with our
troops on the ground and loves this
country and now just wants to support
his community hk shared this photo with
us of his wife and brother-in-law when
they receive news they would be safely
leaving afghanistan on monday
they are now in kuwait last i heard from
the
embassy in kuwait the u.s embassy to say
that they're being processed and uh
once they're uh once they're getting
ready to take off from there and they'll
uh possibly send me you know a
description of the flight itinerary
where they're going bring them here
bring them to the you know where i am so
hopefully that happens i'll go see her
wherever she lands in the united states
and we'll go from there it's funny he
thinks he's going by himself that's cute
although his wife and brother-in-law are
out of harm's way hk says his mission is
far from over my wife she's out of the
danger zone and i am focused on saving
everybody else kyrsten joyce 8 news now
h.k and bryant are currently in north
carolina hoping hk's wife lands there
but if not they'll go to wherever she's
flown hk has lived in las vegas for
eight years his mother and father also
live here will bring you the reunion of
course when he gets to embrace his wife
on u.s soil
up next on politics now a key date where
several unemployment programs will end
is just a few weeks away